congratulations on the new ep you've
been working on these songs for quite a
while right
yes i have so why not so why now why did
it finally come to fruition now
you know what for me kales i feel
like i didn't i didn't have the
worry about a label you know what i mean
and for me i just really wanted to
create from a free place and i and i did
and it was awesome
and not to say that i couldn't before
it's just a different
kind of space and it just felt amazing
and i'm happy that i did
i'm happy that i released it and to be
on
like really honest like it's so strange
like releasing music in this
in this time and space compared to the
time where where we release music you
know what i mean everything's
so different wouldn't you say absolutely
i don't know what the hell's happening i
just said here it is and you do whatever
you're supposed to do with it
like yeah it's so different and i feel
like in our careers especially
like just in that amount of time things
are so different how we
how we buy music how we you know listen
to music how there's been so many
different platforms
it's so different and i was saying it to
someone else i said you know
i said everybody like digest music so
much quicker now
so it's not like a whole setup process
like and i love the way this new
generation is just releasing music like
when they feel something they put it out
and i'm like i'm gonna do that i'm gonna
try that we'll see what happens
i love that yep i'm still here just
waiting for you to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever help